so what we're going to do today is
I'm going to tell you about me I'm going
to tell you about kind of what riot
games does and get you an overview of
that
um I'm going to talk to you guys about
the games that we build and stuff and
then I want to talk about the problems
and the contexts that we solve
I think League of Legends and like these
bigger AAA games have a lot of
non-obvious ways we use machine learning
and I would like to kind of peel back
the curtain a little bit and just show
some of the things we do I'm going to go
into a little bit of some tech deep
Dives but it's not going to be like
something you would see in one of the
more technical tracks it's just going to
be like a highlight of some of the
products I'm going to kind of break them
down at a small level so you can kind of
get like a grasp of what's going on
um
and we're hiring so like if you see this
and you're like dang I want to do like
machine learning for League of Legends
like hit me up hit up my manager hit up
anybody you see who's a recruiter at
Riot tell them you saw my talk like
we're more than happy to take cool
Talent
um so I'm going to talk about me so this
is me that's that's a picture we take
pictures at Riot it's like a big thing
I'm a software engineer or like a
machine learning engineer I don't really
know what you'd call me but I work on
data stuff and I work on machine
learning stuff as a software engineer I
used to be a engineer at doordash my old
manager is also here he's very smart buy
him a buy him a drink if you see him
um before that I was a data engineer at
Adobe I'm a musician and a dad that's my
band circle of size for like a black
metal band we're putting out a record in
a week listen to circle of size check it
out I play drums
um
so I I'm in a team called League data
central
um it is an initiative and
kind of the way we've structured
ourselves at League Studios is a series
of initiatives who do like particular uh
kind of verticals within the game so
there's uh the game engine team which
has a fancy name but I'm not allowed to
say it and they are headed by like Jim
Bowles and some other like really smart
folks who work on like
the game engine and like the tooling
pipelines and like the assets and like
really intense kind of like game devby
stuff that you probably think about when
you think about game development
um there's my team I'm going to mention
a couple folks who work with me there's
our service Ops Team who's kind of like
the sres or like the back end engineers
in general
um and we kind of work all three of us
ideally in tandem to support all the
games that run on something called like
the league Studios engine
and it's worth kind of talking about
that
the leak Studio engine is like if
anyone's familiar with like Unity or
unreal or like these tools that help
developers build video games kind of our
have our own like homegrown one but
that's not the case throughout the whole
company
um League studio is just like a part of
it right and then we have all the other
game studios and we have infrastructure
platform my wife also works there she's
way over there in the corner
um
and the reason I point this out is
because
League data central doesn't really
operate data in a vacuum just like we
don't operate like a game engine in a
vacuum we are a part of a bigger group
there's kind of a
mesh of data organizations that help
build stuff so League data central kind
of sits in this middle place but we also
have like a central data warehouse team
who just think about spark and how you
do spark we have a team who works on our
data catalog and Elation and they kind
of support all that cool stuff and
that's kind of what they're thinking
about
um so that's kind of like a breakdown of
what the people are but like I
I gathered from like talking to people
and like hanging out with folks that
like I should maybe talk about the video
games so like if you know about League
of Legends or team fight tactics like
glaze over your eyes because I'm going
to give a really brief description but
if you don't uh Riot builds a lot of
games we have League of Legends which is
kind of like this 10 year old game at
this point it's very popular we have
Legends of roomtera which is a
uh
uh well it's acronym is to see c g c
which is actually kind of tough to say
but it's a like card game so for those
of you who play like magic the Gathering
or Yu-Gi-Oh it's kind of like that it's
actually my favorite game that we make
um we've ported League of Legends over
to mobile that's the wild Rich version
we have a game called team fight tactics
we have a game called valorent we
partner with a separate studio called
Riot Forge which builds
um
kind of a a smattering of games and
different genres based on the league IP
and like the runetera IP
um so things here are like the ruined
King that was a game that came out
recently on the switch
um there's a game that was just
announced about Silas that's going to
come out that's kind of Hades like which
I'm pretty stoked about
um
I can't play the game in front of you
guys which was like kind of a cool
thought but like just to like briefly
give pictures this is what League of
Legends looks like it's a MOBA if you
don't know what that means don't worry
about it but it's like a 5v5 game where
you kind of like build a composition
with your team and the whole point is to
like overtake the map and you know like
there's lots of different interactions
there's neutral like camps that you guys
can compete over
um
it's been going on for a few years kind
of a similar game in the space is uh
DOTA Dota 2 is like similar
um you shouldn't be surprised that wild
Rick looks exactly the same but it's on
mobile so we have that
um Team fight tactics is really cool and
I want to like spend a second here
because something I talk about later is
very involved with Team fight tactics so
I want to like make sure you folks
understand clearly but team fight
tactics is almost like an auto battling
chess kind of game so you kind of have a
a deck of players or like a bench of
Champions that you kind of build into
compositions and then they like Auto
Battle to win
um
so then like you know the whole point is
to like build better compositions as
kind of the thing that's kind of the
game rolls on by balancing like the
amount of kind of gold you have and like
the composition and the stacks and all
this cool stuff
um definitely check out team fight
tactics if you're looking for something
to do tonight I recommend for those of
you who want to play and don't know what
you're doing to play hyper role
specifically it's fast it's easier and
it's really enjoyable
um and like we've just got a ton more
games so like valerian's over there if
you play tax Shooters this is the ruined
King which is an RPG so if you're into
like Final Fantasy or stuff like that
and we have games that are like in
development right now like our MMO
um which are like kind of r d stuff but
can only talk to you about so much right
before like I start giving away company
secret sauce
um so that's the games uh we have people
who play our games I'm sure you know
that we have a very kind of big fan base
we've been doing this for a long time
and I guess kind of the point I wanted
to call out here is like we have people
who are very dedicated in the cosplaying
community and the lore Community we have
like a bunch of YouTubers who like to
watch and just think about how our game
is we have people who play this
professionally so they're like playing
the game as as a sport and we like pay
them and they're like 19 and they're
like incredibly talented at the game and
I'm like 31 and having a crisis over
like SQL so like it's super tight uh
check them out do the things
um
so synopsis for all of you who walked
into the room and caught up
um
we make games my team specifically
thinks about Games built on the league
engine which is like Unity but
proprietary we're talking about kind of
three games today lol TFT and wild Rift
there are more but I'm really gonna
mostly talk about those
um and we kind of have like a couple
different places we think about machine
learning and data products we think
about them in the video game we think
about them around the video game like
when you're getting into the queue or
when you log in or whatever and of
course we have like back of house data
analytics kind of stuff
um
and I think to best understand
when we build what it's good to think
about the different kind of people that
we work with so these are the logos of
the different regions of runetera so
like if you don't know about runetera
welcome to the club probably a lot of
you don't uh that's okay you don't need
to know what these symbols are uh it's
just like the different areas uh fun
fact the only typo in this Slide the
only type on this deck is the next slide
see if you can find it
um so I want to talk about
I guess kind of the the division of of
people and I want to walk through what
they think about what their context is
and what their problem space is
um so obviously there's us there's data
people right we do we do the things
um we have
a trade of folks who are kind of
colloquially called game designers so
they're really thinking about like
how do people play this game who is it
for like how do we like tie it into the
lore what changes are we making that are
affecting the lore like are we making
the game broken are people still going
to have fun and they're really kind of
thinking about it from like the the
person who really just like loves video
games perspective
there's operations who deeply care about
making sure nothing's broken
um and this may seem weird to call out
but uh just for some context League of
Legends has
shipped every two weeks for like the
last six years so every two weeks a new
patch has gone out a lot of that is
thanks to the operations folks there's
one exception which was 13-2 uh you can
hit me up enough you can hit me up in
office hours to hear about 13 too but it
was a fun whole thing I was talking to I
think I was talking to you about it
after at dinner
um and then there are Engineers now when
you see Engineers you probably think of
me
or maybe Max up here or other Engineers
but I want to caution and and say that
there are different kinds of engineers
in the world and these Engineers that
we're talking about are typically
uh very good at building video games
that is like a big skill about their
stuff and they might not really know
about data and in some cases they know
even less about data and we'll get into
that but first let's start easy and
let's talk about kind of designers so
like
the the key here is like when we
interact with designers what we're
really doing is like
we have a ton of data scientists on
League data central and they will embed
directly with game design teams that's
like where they're most impactful so
like when there's a game designer
thinking about hey I want to introduce
like a new Dragon into the neutrals Camp
a data scientist can kind of be there to
be like well you sure you want to do
that
70 of all players don't go after the
dragon or like we've got this kind of
response we've got this kind of
sentiment around these kinds of dragons
so they can really kind of be there and
help do these kind of decision making
things early I guess kind of throwing
back to the last talk that we just had
um there's a big aspect of
interpretability that is kind of
important at League
and like the idea here is the game's
just not fun if like some model plays
the game for you it's just it's just not
fun it's not cool if like you go into
the item shop and it's like oh hey this
is your opposing team they're all weak
to this by Trinity force and just like
destroy everybody it's not fun you want
it to be like a fair thing so there's a
lot of work that kind of goes into like
a trade-off between like oh well we can
build this like super sick game that can
like you know play the game and do all
this cool stuff and the designer asking
like well why would I do that does it
make the game fun or does it make it
worse and like just kind of this this
drive that like we're not a support
function which I hope for those of you
who work in data kind of know like and
embody that pain I feel like often
especially bigger corporations you kind
of just feel like the dashboard dudes
like you went to school for all this
cool stuff and then like you built
Tableau dashboards and it's like okay
that's not what we do we can do more so
there's a lot of work here
um
now for operations it's a little weird
they don't want you to break the game
like don't break the game and that
doesn't mean like don't check in busted
code we can take care of busted code but
like don't make me have to go on to
Reddit and tell people that the game's
not going to come out or that trundle is
still broken or that this art still
looks Jank don't do that but also don't
break the game like don't stick some
model that is supposed to be important
to matchmaking or MMR and then have it
go down because that's like core to the
player experience so we need to be very
like precise in our communication with
operation folks to tell them like yeah
we're we're upgrading Bento ml so now
all of our models could run a bit slower
and we're not really sure what that
means so we have to kind of do a lot of
this work to provide like accurate
controls over this stuff so they can and
turn stuff off like it's horrible
getting paged at two in the morning
because like you know some model is just
like totally Jank because coefficients
got lost or whatever and all you really
need to do is just restart the service
like we have a network Operation Center
who look at graphs who do this
monitoring they should be able to
restart the service let's give them the
tools to do that so I can go to bed
um and then there's engineers
uh this is a nice slide and the the the
why it's a nice slide is because what we
want to do is as like machine learning
practitioners or data practitioners is
when we work with Engineers of various
skills
um we want them to make sure they deeply
understand the overlap between what
we're doing and the tools that they
build and we want to make sure that
whatever we build like looks like
something they would want even if that
means it's not like hot or sexy data
science work so we might not use Python
everywhere because Engineers think
python is really slow so okay great
we'll Fork this and write it in C plus
plus fine but let us run python over
here
um kind of the trade-off here is then
we're working like really deeply with
different engineering teams to like
influence roadmap to help us like not
suck one year later on and there's a lot
of work that we do to explain Concepts
and machine learning and data and
it it's funny I I had this conversation
once with uh like one of our architects
who work on the game engine and
having to like explain
likelihoods and probability functions
and like yes I need a floating point and
yes neural networks need like a lot of
floating Point numbers is maybe
sometimes a bit difficult but like to
give them context it's because like
machine learning has always been in
League of Legends and they've had to do
like this this is a decision tree
serialized into C plus plus no labels no
nothing face is garbage right they were
just given this giant C plus function of
a bunch of if else statements and all
they could really do is just write this
comment and call us some insights guy
which like yeah
that sucks
so what we're trying to do is not do
this anymore this this would be a good
thing I see like two people taking
pictures of this so go ahead I challenge
you to find out what value 127 was and
what value 32 was in this decision tree
uh I sure don't know what it was
all right
um so let's talk about decision science
so this is kind of what I've coined a
collection of products that we build
that are around the realm of like
back of Health stuff or kind of
understanding The Meta nothing that
would really change the game or in a
round game experience but help give
people information to make a good
decision hence the name
um
so I'm actually going to jump forward
one slide and then jump back just to
give you guys the scale of why this kind
of stuff is important this is just like
a graph of games that we've processed in
the past couple of days we have multiple
shards which is to say multiple
deployments of League of Legends some of
them process a million games a day some
of them process 500 000 games a day
we've got a lot of these so there's a
lot of games a lot of different kinds of
people playing and it's like not
feasible to put all of that into like
one Tableau dashboard or like a superset
dashboard maybe super set I don't know
superset scales like that does it
[Laughter]
great fantastic good pitch
um so let me talk let me talk about how
we
um
get data just for a second there's some
kind of cool insightful stuff we do here
but
um so the first thing I'm going to start
kind of from the top and go down I know
this is like a lot of text but I'll try
to just talk a little bit but
um
we're a game so we need to get a lot of
data from the game so we
I haven't seen this in too many places
that I've worked uh in like the data
space like when when I was working at
doordash or when I have folks who worked
at bird or whatever or Lyft or any of
those kind of places like getting the
holistic journey of like a a delivery or
ride or a rental of a scooter typically
is like joining a bunch of data sets and
like bunching them together and like
aggregating them and understanding
what's going on
um League of Legends and TFT happens to
be uh server authoritative which is like
a game design mechanism which means the
game server rules all so every request
comes into the game server the game
server says yes check you can do that
and then we can get kind of get out of
there this is a really interesting data
source it is basically fully
referentially integral because
everything that had to happen before the
game had to come into the game server
everything that happens in the game
server can be recorded
and we basically are like running right
on top of the component that does the
main thing of the business the games so
this is like a really interesting data
source we've kind of like standardized
into like dumping out all of this in
like a shadow State kind of listener
it's actually the first thing I worked
on when I joined this team so we
listened for all these different game
events
bulk it up a memory toss it out into a
file and then zip that up and jupit on
into the onto the data warehouse
um
this is good for a lot of good reasons
it sucks for some other reasons like the
state changes every two weeks so like
you're always changing Telemetry code
it's like never ending because
everyone's always adding a new event
um and like it is Risky Business holding
anything in a linked list or in a STD
Vector in a game server for Telemetry
especially when like you could blow up
the game server so like we've had some
embarrassing crashes because like the
Telemetry buffer got too big or whatever
so
um we also do some stuff that probably
everyone does we scrape service
databases to kind of get dimensional
data this is well studied you guys have
probably thought about this all the time
um
kind of shitty there are just things
that we have to think about like
Services don't know about the games the
Telemetry is often the last thing people
think about so you have to do a lot of
munging to get the stuff you want we do
have an event stream for microservices
to kind of send fact data out
um this is great service teams can fire
and forget this is bad because service
teams can fire and forget so like
double-edged sword the destination gets
super bloated but it's like a shared
infrastructure and we only have to
maintain one Library so good and bad
things
um we also do this work around designing
the or like ingesting the design
pipeline so like we have a lot of tools
I don't know if people are familiar with
like Maya or other kind of like 3D
modeling tools but we have our kind of
own Suite of tooling that we build
um that sits on top of perforce so we
actually have a lot of tooling that like
goes into prayer Force pulls out
versions of these Json files
reinterprets the state and like puts
into the data warehouse it's really nice
all the metadata could ever care about
is in there like is this skin yellow yes
the metadata will be in there but this
sucks to ingest this is just like a
giant pain Point um that we will
probably never get away from so great so
let me talk to you guys about metapangoo
so I'm going to jump over a slide so
this is matapangu this is a one of the
data products we build that kind of
leverages all this data
um and
if you kind of recall the TFT picture I
showed you earlier
there's often a question from game
designers of like what is a good
composition and what are my players
playing I don't want to go watch Twitch
streams for like six hours to figure
that out I don't want to go play games
myself for like 13 hours and figure that
out I just want to like know what is a
good composition what is winning what is
losing what are the trends about it and
this is matapangu so this is a
um
it's like an LDA uh model that
kind of joined and Aggregates a bunch of
things and it tosses it through like a
regression model to get some of these
kind of like coefficients to understand
like what are like winning trades what
are most likely traits to win what are
most likely things to change how are
people like building their compositions
and this is really nice uh because like
there's just no more guesswork that
folks have had to do so like in Old ver
in older versions of TFT a composition
change would be made and often it was
the wrong composition choice so like a
week later a micro patch would go out
and it would like rebuff certain Champs
or like nurse some Champs and this was
just kind of like a designer's life for
like the first couple of weeks of a
patch they were just constantly kind of
tweaking it because they didn't really
know what was going on uh metapengu is
fairly real time
um like every day every couple of hours
which is good enough given kind of the
the scale so like game designers are
actually able to get like a really nice
understanding of like okay in this
particular comp I think statuani is like
super strong so like maybe let's Nerf
sejuani a little bit so seguani doesn't
just keep like absolutely winning
um this is like this is something that
Emily Hansen has been working on on our
team and I guess his biggest claim to
fame was in set nine and a half I think
it was uh when the set hit our internal
like player environments
one particular composition had just
happened its way into like a 100 win
rate so like if you played with uh I
think it was like
God I think it was Yumi and
God I don't even know I think it might
have been like Yumi and Jarvan or
something and if you happened your way
into this composition like it just
didn't matter you just won like the
composition was just perfect you had
perfect self-healing and like people
were just like dominating on PPE
um luckily this did not go to Reddit
because it didn't go live because
metapangoo looked really awkward for a
game designer one day and they were like
oh I need to Nerf you me Nerf do me
all done uh by the way if you play Yumi
you're a terrible person okay thank you
um all right so now I'm going to talk
about some in game models
um
so like I guess before I get into it
like for the data engineering components
like Steven Pascal and Jacob werderitz
they've been working really hard on like
giving us a nice clean data warehouse so
like
this is gonna sound like we just went
from like these end of game Telemetry
files to Big models but like that's not
the case so like I'm just not talking
very much about the data warehouse here
um so
when you think about in-game models
you're probably a little confused and
you're probably asking yourself well
what do you mean Ian so what I mean is a
machine learning model that is either
baked into the C plus binary doing some
evaluations or the game server depends
on a service that runs some evaluations
to make a decision
and
these may be non-obvious but what I'd
like to do is kind of break some of
these down for you so there are a couple
different ways to like slice these
models up and I like to think of it as
like when do you need to like
uh when would an inference result change
significantly so
we have this idea of like patch by patch
systems these are going to be like
recommendation systems that I'll talk
about with you guys they're like are
Precision detection system
uh that'll change maybe every couple
patches or something there are game by
game things and this is around like are
you inting which don't worry I'll
describe what that means like are you
into are you playing bad are you just
being a those kind of things
um there are second by second models
which are things we're still kind of
building about in their frame by frame
models which are still kind of thinking
about I would love to come back to data
Council in like two years and talk more
about these things in particular in like
a more technical track uh so I don't
know if you dig C plus plus come to data
Council 2025 and hopefully I'll be
talking about it
um so let's talk about patch by patch so
uh this thing up here in the top
uh right top right top right uh top
right yes yeah great top right is the uh
item recommender the thing right below
it is a jungle path recommender both of
these were built by Kellen wolf
um so what these are are your like very
standard well not standard but like uh
very uh consumable collaborative
filtering uh models so these are models
that just like understand like oh what
item composition on your player tends to
win the most what item composition is
the most popular
um
so you can kind of think of it as like
an R backs over the probability of the
item
hopefully that's nothing too kind of
crazy uh all I'm just highlighting here
is we have like seven of these in game
so we have a bunch of different
recommenders they all run through like
this like airflow patch into the C plus
binary that gets built like at compile
time in red
um what that looks like is we've had to
like generously extend our build system
to like reach out to S3 and other
analytic data warehouses to eat all this
data turn it into like C plus assets and
build it into the game
um so that means all of our testing
happens in like databricks pipelines and
this kind of led to our design of like
okay what we'll do is every patch we
will just go through all possible
permutations generate a giant batch of
predictions and then embed it into the
game so when the players patch they just
patch down this game this this like
recommendation data this is really
similar to doing like batch inference
like if you just like compute a model
over a bunch of results stored in a
database or a cache and you look it up
this is very similar except for we're
talking about like I don't know a buffer
of memory in like the game server
um
so this is
kind of the most novel approach we have
these recommenders and kind of any of
these in-game systems all kind of like
standardized into this workflow
um of like spark to do all the
aggregations and all of our spark models
in there uh we translate it into S3 and
we push it into P4 and by the way if
you've never worked on prayer Force like
if you see this like middle thing and
you see like build uh perforce socks it
is really tough to write automation
around prayer Force for data tooling
especially Big Data tooling luckily it's
not like git where it's like a large
file kind of like blows git up but
perforce is not fun it's very tricky
there are a lot of semantics that you
just don't think about
um we have this custom library that my
team maintains to do kind of the ETL or
the data activation into the game and
then there's like a crap ton of game
engine code that will like load all of
this data I can't really talk about any
of the game engine code that's all
proprietary but it's all C plus plus
anyway so like you guys probably don't
care
um
so then we have kind of a collection of
models that uh sit at this kind of game
by game kind of inference so like a game
ends we reach out to a service and we
make some decision
um
riots if you haven't gathered uh has
built a lot of things uh from scratch
and part of that is just because like
the AAA gaming industry was maybe in a
weird position when they started so
tools didn't quite fit uh We've also
been around for a long time so like our
compute and uh kind of container
orchestration system called R cluster is
actually like three separate wrappers
around like one uh mesos two kubernetes
and three something called Admiral which
we also built by hand which is like our
own container system
and if you're really interested in that
there's like a seven piece blog blog
post on like the tech blog and it's all
very long so feel free to go like Google
R cluster Riot games you can find out
all about this
um but for our purposes
why I bring this up is because this
leads us to um
kind of the constraint that all of our
ml Services have which is we run Java
and the front end and we have service
configuration that is controlled by the
knock all over the place so there's this
very rich ecosystem of tools that we
need to integrate with there's this very
rich ecosystem of machine learning tools
that we want to use and we need to smash
them together in order to do anything
good so that's what we're going to talk
about here
um so there's a couple of Concepts I
just want to break down
um because like I've pretty much already
explained the tech but like
what are we doing when we're doing kind
of a game by game inference the best
example is feeding detection so feeding
in League of Legends is you're
intentionally playing bad
um you're just like giving the other
team as much of an advantage as they can
possibly have by making your team worse
and this is difficult because like
players could just be having a bad day
or they could be new and like it's very
easy to see a new player as a sucky
player but those are very two different
things so like there was no way to sort
of heuristically solve this and although
they tried
um my team and a lot of uh a few other
data scientists on the team worked
really hard on like building a kind of
feed and detection model that could one
generates probability distribution to
failure and two then assess if your kill
was like a likely kill that was feeding
so I go into a lot of this in a blog
post I did with
um the Seattle data guy so if you like
Google the Seattle data guy League of
Legends I talk about this a bit more but
just to kind of highlight some of the
things I talk about in that article
um
these kinds of models can get kind of
arbitrarily complex in this case it's
kind of like a two-stage model which
I've seen a little bit before so there's
like a sort of generative model up front
not to be confused with generative AI
um that does some kind of like uh
reinterpretation of the data into a
probability distribution and then
there's a classifier that can just run
and kind of sample from this
distribution and understand okay did
this kill actually look like a death or
like was this a feeding kill so then
when a game ends we can eat the data we
can go through all the kills and we can
kind of assess was this a likely feeding
death or not and then we can kind of
send that information out to other
services and do player bands
um so there's only one me and there's a
lot of data scientists so I don't care
about what they model this is some stand
code
I don't know Stan but I do care about
like how they do their feature
engineering and how they model so one of
the tools we build is called Oracle lens
for those of you who attended the Deep
check
the Deep checks talk on on Tuesday this
is actually very similar like a lot of
what we were doing in Oracle lens is
very similar to deep checks but with uh
some wrapping around like python data
classes to give kind of a nice interface
to our data warehouse to S3 into our
like kind of custom feature store
um so this was kind of giving data
scientists a bit more guard rails to be
able to like write a model with good
feature engineering and not like I don't
know accidentally miss a one hot
encoding or something
um
so that means that they can do what like
almost whatever they want at inference
time
um so like this is this particular
inference code it's just scipy if you
don't remember your binomial probability
distribution I don't blame you it's
there on the slide go read your stats
book if you want to learn more about the
binomial probability distribution
um
but I guess like the the interesting
part about all this is so they've got
this model in in Python great they read
from this feature store used in your
library great but like how does it
actually get somewhere is it really kind
of important uh discussion so
if you break it down by like the machine
learning life cycle and then you like
step back there are really just two
components we think about we think about
how does it get trained and how does it
get deployed
um so for training we're like big
databricks users we use a craps on the
data bricks so almost everything happens
in data bricks if it has to be a little
more advanced we do provide like ec2
machines for our data scientists
um with like connections into the spark
world if if they need it so they can
like build their packages they can
upload it into like an internal
artifactory and then we leverage Bento
ml for those of you who don't know Bento
ml it's like this really slick model
serving layer built on built on top of a
Clipper that came out of Berkeley
um
and
the reason we do this is because we're
kind of like hamstrung to this Java
layer that we need to integrate with so
all of our Rich tooling around like
request handling and like session
management and like credential and token
validation has to happen up in a Java
layer and the python layer just has to
do like a model evaluation so
Bento is kind of the nicest to
containerize so we went with Bento it
has a lot of nifty advantages it has a
lot of constraints like models have to
be served out of like a Pi Pi registry
so you always have to download and
install a pipei registry so what I'm
getting at here is because of kind of
the ecosystem of tools that existed at
riots and the
necessity to use like open source
Technologies in Python our design got
really limited really fast so we've
ended up with this kind of Bento ml kind
of system
um kind of what we're exploring uh now
is
we have another model in production
um that is a bit
more sensitive to latency shall we say
so if it's kind of a loose latency model
there is a world where it's like all
right data scientists I've built you
some Frameworks I've built you some
tools
go build whatever model you want just
use the tooling that I provide you but I
will not keep tabs on your SLA and this
is nice because like some ml models only
get like 80 requests a week or something
and like that's a bit more feasible for
someone to manage but if it's a really
tight SLA if like the game server
depends on a response or like if the
decision is like do we pay this person
right now for their competitive
Integrity or not
um
there's only one me so they get to use
the framework that I know so when it
goes into the to the more tight world
there's a lot of like collaboration with
like us machine learning Engineers to
like pick the right framework to do the
right thing which is a much even a more
limited set so again for the plug if
you're hiring and you're specialized in
like an ml framework hit me up I could
use more people
um so I'm pretty much done just some
future work that we're talking about to
kind of hype Folks up
um we're working a lot with pymc and
like generative modeling to try to do
like you can think of it as like
generative load testing on top of data
um
we're working more with like finding
better ways to run machine learning
models besides like pre-aggregating data
and loading it in the game binary we'd
love to ship models without having to do
a decision tree serializing C plus plus
and without having to write linear
regression.cpp but we'll see where we
end up
and we're constantly looking to like
expand our tooling and our
experimentation space expect especially
um
and this is all because
um you know we as kind of a a data
products team we're just trying to like
own our destiny within League of Legends
and we're trying to make sure that like
machine learning looks a lot less big
and a lot less scary to our game teams
so we can deliver more things to our
players
uh so that's been me that's thresh up in
the corner that's my wife's favorite uh
like lead character thank you all so
much
foreign
[Music]